i just think our brains are not built
for this i think we've the human beings
have now outstripped what our brains
were built for and we're building
systems that we don't know the
consequences of and and more than that
we're then building
almost in the way that we're talking
about with with carbohydrates it's like
we built an entire dietary system to
provide to a piece of junk food that our
body craves because it used to be rare
in the wilderness and i think sugar's
definitely that yeah exactly and i feel
like that's that's exactly what you used
to have to fight bees for sugar you know
you paid a high price for it
right exactly and now i feel like that
it's the same sort of thing with regard
to
social media and the metaverse and all
this stuff i think we're constructing
worlds that are just designed for the
the sugar and the dopamine release and
yeah i'm afraid that we're going to live
inside it as reading robert nozick the
other day um and he has this thing in
um
in
man in uh uh determined
uh the state and anarchy uh and um
he uh he has something that he posits he
calls the experience machine and his his
basic theory is that if you
are
if you are given the choice to live
inside a machine where you get all of
the feedback loops of of
pleasure and it feels real and all of
this stuff
you still wouldn't choose to live in it
because you would understand that you're
not having any real world impact but the
problem is what if everybody else is
inside the experience machine with you i
think that the the libertarian basis for
society is kind of falling away because
if everything i think i think the
problem with with thought experiments
like that is that
they're actually not possible like so
and i think that's actually a technical
problem with with conundrums like that
there's a
conundrum claire lehmann talked to me
about this editor of quillette she was
asking this question it's one of these
philosophical conundrums and so this is
a rough one
so imagine that you're in amsterdam
during world war ii and the nazis are
everywhere and you have a jewish family
in the
attic and you're up there with the baby
and there's 25 nazi officers and the
ground floor the baby starts to cry
do you smother the baby
you save all the people upstairs and
claire who is a mother of a very young
child at that time said her response was
don't ask me such stupid questions which
i think is actually the right response
and it's more embodied response right
and you you can trap your philosophical
cognition into weird corners but that
doesn't mean that your fundamental
intuitions are flawed
this is right with this nozick thing
it's it's like well if you could not
have a body
yeah no
you know you're grounded out in the
world well that that's that's the
rejection of derek parfit right so derek
harfit's entire moral theories the
trolley problems and you can decide how
morality is constructed based on trolley
problems and people like well that's not
really how morality is constructed it's
not all based on edge cases it's not
really how it's constructed at all it
has to be embodied for example and
that's a crucial issue you know and so
the the notion that a set of semantic
philosophical propositions even
coherently organized constitutes the
ethical world and that ethics is top
down from the semantic space into the
embodied states that's
there's some truth in that because
there's feedback right we think about
ethics and we can we can move around the
edges of ethics and so forth but it's
within a game that's already established
and that game is actually established
through embodied negotiation first so
when you see moses leading his people
through the desert they're all fighting
and scrapping away right and then he
sits as judge of them for a very long
period of time it's months or years even
so much that his father-in-law says you
have to stop doing right because it's
exhausting right it's after that he
receives the revelations from on high
and so my sense of that psychologically
is it's a story about the fact that
morality is encoded in our behavior in a
deep level
and so deep we actually don't understand
the morality but then now and then we
get an imaginative insight into the
moral pattern and then we get a semantic
representation of the imaginative
insight and that's this revelation it's
like here's a moral rule it's like
wolves suddenly becoming semantically
conscious of the
authority relationships in their pack
that's really good i like that a lot
that's quite good like 20 years ago
put a lot of effort into that yeah
there's a there's a big kind of rich
debate in jewish philosophy over whether
moses is right to listen to jethro so
jethro comes and says you need to you
need to devolve authority to lower
levels you need the the prince's you
need the judges of the tens and then the
judges the hundreds yeah yeah which is a
lovely way of thinking about it too
because they parse out the i thought
that's what should have happened in iraq
right kill the tyranny well what do you
do you have to establish a hierarchical
local authority exactly so centralized
control doesn't work but one of the big
questions is whether in doing that
is moses setting the stage for
all of the chaos that follows because
once you give up the authority that he
has the direct authority and you have
now layers of of authority below him how
much authority can you devolve to layers
below you without giving up the the
prime authority at the top that is like
one of the cardinal questions of life
isn't it you know if you have a family
you want to devolve authority and
facilitate autonomy
and the question is how much can you do
that without
without generating disunity and i would
say it depends on the value of the gold
that unites you
and and then that brings up another
question and this is a question i would
say for the moral relativists
um i was talking to rupert sheldrake in
in cambridge he has lots of wild ideas
but i was
conducting a seminar there
on
the nature of the uniting ideal so it
was imitation of the divine ideal say
you need a higher order
aim to unite subordinate drives right so
the question then is what becomes the
highest order
ethic right it's like the pyramid with a
gold cap on the top or the washington
monument with a pyramid on top of it
with this aluminum cap on something's at
the top and the thing that's at the top
is actually qualitatively distinctive
from all the things that are subordinate
to it so the question is what's that
highest order uniting principle and
well one answer to that that the three
religions that are based on books
have proposed is it has something to do
with the authority of the word
and christianity that's developed into
the notion of the divine word and you
see that saturating judaism as well and
that's at least in part because the
thing that has to be super ordinate is
freedom of
it's it's not freedom of thought exactly
it's more like freedom of consciousness
because
logos isn't thought it's not logical
either it's much broader than that it's
more like consciousness itself
and the reason i think that's true
technically is because
imagine that consciousness and attention
are in some sense isomorphic right i
mean when we pay attention to something
we become conscious of it okay
consciousness consciousness is the
mechanism that generates proximal
solutions and
dissolves and regenerates them and so
all the proximal solutions have to be
made subordinate to respect for the
process that generates all okay yeah
exactly
i think it's a cardinal
presupposition of psychotherapy because
what you do in psychotherapy is you
allow people maximal freedom of
expression
right you don't impose your views on
them even if the freudians use free
association say whatever comes into your
mind and it turns out that that process
of
untrammeled expression in good faith is
actually curative it actually makes
people
better it leads them to what they're
afraid of that that's one of the
consequences
of free speech right because you sort of
you tend to circulate around what
bothers you and what disturbs you and so
untrembled freedom of expression will
lead you to the source of your fears and
then you can confront those fears and
then in confronting them you can get
more courageous that's all part of that
obviously one of one of the big
arguments that that is used with regard
to freedom of speech now is whether
freedom of speech if it
threatens the structure of freedom of
speech
yeah right right that's one of the sort
of weird loops right exactly
the germans yeah the germans have an
entire term for it which they they
describe tolerance for intelligence
right exactly like it's a threat to the
democracy can you can you suppress the
speech well i think i i thought about
this a lot i mean i think you can equate
free speech with the struggling for
truth
struggling towards truth because if
you're speaking freely
you're trying to investigate rather than
to to
convince or to claim especially if it's
during exploration so let's say that
you're guided by the desire for the
truth so you've made a commitment in
faith that
exploring the truth is going to be
curative in the broadest sense
and then you might say well is that the
superordinate value and i actually don't
think it is
i think the superordinate value is love
and i think
i thought about how to define love sort
of practically i would say
it's the best in me serving the best in
you that's one way of thinking about it
but it's also the desire that all things
flourish to the degree that that's
possible so you can imagine you have a
fundamental orientation on life it could
be mephistophelia in the faustian sense
so mephistopheles in earth is faust
he he says this twice in the first
voyage and the second volume so
girtha was insisting on this
mephistophilian view
the suffering of being is so intolerable
it would be better if it wasn't
eradicated completely that's the memphis
defending view and that's a powerful
argument you know and i talked to
stephen fry about god and
and fry's very interested in mythology
very oriented for his narrative and he's
a wise person
and he said he was angry and he said
well i i call them all i call them out
for bone cancer and children it's like
fair enough you know there's a lot of
undeserved suffering in the world and
you might think well the whole bloody
thing should be brought to a halt
my sense of that is if you pursue that
path you make everything worse
you don't make everything better you
start to become part of the process that
generates the suffering you're objecting
to so you take the opposite of that
viewpoint it's like no we just we want
to make everything better for everyone
including our enemies and that's the
orientation so i would also say that's a
that's faith it's like i'm going to act
as if
i wish that everything could be as good
as it could be and then maybe even
better than that and decide that being
itself is worth the effort and and the
repair and then inside that then i think
truth works because but there's been
mutuality there obviously i mean the
person that you love has to love you
back right the the sort of unrequited
love you're talking about on a broad
level if it's only one way you're going
to end up giving an enormous amount of
leverage to people who are not
interested yeah well that i wouldn't
call that that's why you have to be wise
as a serpent you know is that it it does
demand reciprocity but i would say that
if it's mature love and not naive love
and they're very those are very
different things they're like the
difference between naive trust and
mature trust naive trust is everyone's
out for the good of everyone and no one
will ever hurt me that's naive trust and
you hit someone malevolent and that just
blows into pieces right it might bring
you down like with it you know because a
lot of people get traumatized by
malevolence but courageous trust is i
know perfectly well you're full of
snakes just like me
but you know we can meet as men and
women of goodwill and we can move
towards the good together and the
freedom of our discourse will facilitate
that and if we orient ourselves properly
then we'll enter into a joint enterprise
that's aimed towards the good
and that that works